something very strange happened this
week by two personalities
that
you know when you think about ray daly
or george soros you think george soros
is what he's the biggest funder of
antifa he's the biggest founder you
don't think about george soros who would
say let's be careful with china but
here's what happened this week very
interesting
one story is a business insider story
about ray dalio whom i interviewed one
of my favorite interviews that i did
hedge from billionaire radio says
investors shouldn't ignore investing
opportunities in china even after the
recent market turmoil business insider
billionaire investor radio told
bloomberg that opportunities in china
and singapore can't be neglected it's a
part of the world that one can't neglect
and not only because of the
opportunities it provides
but you lose the excitement if you're
not there
dalio said when asked about his family
office plan in the region and so our
objective is to be there both
economically and investment wise this is
ray dalio then george soros comes out
and it's a cnn story he calls out ray
dalio george soros calls out blackrock's
china blunder the billionaire financier
philanthropist thinks blackrock has made
a huge miscalculation on china blackrock
recently started offering investment
products to individual chinese investors
as the country's first uh entirely
foreign owned fund management from
basaro slammed the move claiming the
company appears to misunderstand
president xi's china soros highlighted
ji's recent crackdown on private
business which she sees as proof that
the regime regards all chinese companies
as instruments of the one-party state he
also referenced an enormous crisis
brewing in china's real estate market
and ji's effort to redistribute wealth
these trends he said do not augur well
for foreign investors soros also thinks
that blackrock's initiative is a threat
to democracies because the money
invested in china will help prop up
president xi's regime which is
repressive at home and aggressive abroad
very confusing for soros to make a
comment like that about china who would
know better than him who would know
better than him who would know better
than that but but for him to say
stay away from china
that's uh you know you mentioned
something earlier really really a droid
about the inner circle having special
yeah
this to me reeks and that's the pure
speculation but this to me reeks of a
guy who was promised a seat on the inner
circle did everything he was told to do
funded everybody he was told to fund
and didn't get a seat on the inner
circle that he was used that he was
never going to be a part of it do you
think this is a direct thing between him
and dalio or him in the current
administration i think it's somebody
that tried to get in
to bed with g
and then found out who she really is and
this is this is the truth of the matter
and this is something the whole world
has to understand that's actually not
bad about who xi jinping is by the way
that's actually not bad
ji jinping
is going he is going
to take over the world or he is going to
die trying people do not pay attention
to what's coming out of china they do
not pay attention when this man speaks
xi jinping is is a
an ambitious man on a level we haven't
seen in a hundred years your guy general
spaulding talks about this and there's
also been other people that you've
interviewed with on the 100 year
marathon xi jinping has accelerated that
progress and he is completely unabashed
in his own
speeches about his plans for for the
future and they they do not include a
world of democratic response to
government
he thinks government
should be in control of everything he
thinks there should be one world
government and it should be his
government under his control uh he
believes in global competence i think
that's great news though let me tell you
why i think that's great news here's why
it's great news
say you and i hate each other we
sincerely hate each other we're enemies
whatever you're a real estate company
i'm a real estate com we can't stand
each other
you defend uh one guy i defend this guy
that guy's a really bad guy but you keep
defending him okay
so you go in bed with them and try to do
business with him he royally screws you
over
royally
which is this kind of thing which this
kind of seems like it then you sit there
and say freaking pat he's not as bad as
i thought he was let me call pat then so
he
indirectly got us closer which is a good
thing
so the fact that g is doing that in
china and it's now getting democrats and
republicans to both agree on the fact
that you cannot take china lightly that
is a very very that's a very good news
for america
if we can we can oppose a lot of
different things it's fine but there's
one thing you do not want the left and
the right to not just not agree on and
that's china is that my enemy's enemy is
now my ally was that what that yeah so
she essentially quite true she
essentially made soros defend america
with sorrows
you know his rapture after 20 years of
destabilizing america are you kidding me
soros
is maybe one of the most hated guys in
america on many different lists because
the guy's got power money and he's a
manipulator and literally actively
destabilizing the country no no and he
he's involved in a lot of different
things that he did so so when i saw this
message i'm like what the hell is going
on for saurus
not everything's black and white there's
a lot of grey and and all this like
even in the middle east like even like
you use your syria example
you have the shiites and the sunnis and
then isis and they're fighting al-qaeda
but al-qaeda is not friends in the
taliban
sunni and then actually the in uh the uh
we're friends with these people up here
and then in kashmir they have fighting
with them and it's just like you know
what it reminds me you can't even see
remember in uh the last batman movie the
christopher nolan with bane tom hardy
playing bain and then uh you know the
the businessman thinks that he's got
bain under control and he's like you get
over here and baine's like i'm already
here and he says i've you know he
finally puts his hand on the guy's
shoulder leave oh no don't leave i'm in
control here do you feel in charge and
then the guy realizes in this moment oh
man i made a deal with the devil like
and then you know and he turns to the
guy and he says i paid you a small
fortune and bain looks at him and says
this gives you power over me
snap and not xi jinping xi jinping is
looking at all these capitalist dummies
saying you know what i've given you but
i love that i've given you 20 years of
power i love that here's why i love that
i love
that a person like that reveals his
ambitions publicly
because now it unites
two different parties i love it because
you're on the tv but but it but listen
sorrows has influence with the left yes
they listen to sorrows so when he says
it you have to know like imagine the
people like okay who said it o'reilly
said it it must be right okay who said
it anderson cooper it must be wrong okay
who said it don lemon he must be rachel
madden must be right hey tuck across
from us there is that community so now
okay george soros said that china sucks
that's fine i i actually think this is
great now
there's a part of it which you know you
heard what rudy giuliani says well i
supported him for the governorship
because i needed money for funding
that's politics right there you just
heard it right he said that so we don't
know that part of what happened who got
offended who got upset because at that
level when you're a billionaire man
you're most your life you've been
winning a lot of the fights
you've been winning a lot if you're a
billionaire right it's not like you've
been losing you've been winning a lot
you've been losing too but you've been
winning a lot so you're not accustomed
to not being right
so soros maybe
is not happy with somebody we don't know
about yeah josh is 91 years old by the
way but but he is just to put it in
perspective it's not like
he's got big plans for himself like you
said he wants to sit
and be in the inner circle with china
his kids too his kids are just like
himself
no i don't i don't know if you you you
what's your point with that no no just
pointing out that's how old he is all
this [ __ ] yeah but 91 years old if do
you think a guy that gets to his age
kirk accordion was doing deals at 99
years old before he died i mean john
wooden died at 99 years old at ronald
reagan hospital in l.a so do you think a
guy like that
that you think the fire is missing do
you think the fire is not there that's a
true believer is the fire missing
probably not are the skills still where
they're at
pull up a picture of george that matters
my father matters father at 101 was
talking about opening up businesses so
when that's in your head okay and he
made it to 104 103. so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]